l'académie des neuf dessinez c'est gagné
motus depuis soixante dix ans les jeux
télé passionne les français diffusé en
matinée dans l'après midi ou parfois
même en prime time il a uni chaque jour
des milliers de téléspectateurs
est ce que vous êtes en forme
si la plupart du temps les gagnants
repartent avec une encyclopédie certains
jeux peuvent littéralement changé la vie
de leurs participants
[Applaudissements]
et enfants s'ils sont nombreux en 2004
soutenez-vous marie a remporté un
million d'euros dans qui veut gagner des
millions oui
[Applaudissements]
margot quant à elle empoché cinq cent
trente mille euros en 2020 dans
n'oubliez pas les paroles c'est beaucoup
d'émotion je suis désolé sans oublier
les trois plus grands gagnants des 12
coups de midi bol avec 691 1000 euros
eric avec 921 1000 euros est désormais
bruno avec un million 26000 107 euros
vous avez battu tous les records j'ai de
soi ce qui fait de lui le plus grand
gagnant tous jeux confondus
une somme d'argent conséquente qui peut
parfois faire perdre la tête alors
jalousie argent notoriété les jeux télé
peut-il faire péter les plombs
merci à vous d'être la syrie je suis
très contente de voir merci j'ai
l'impression de te connaître à fond
parce que j'ai suivi j'adorais voilà
dans les douze que me dis moi tu sais je
je bosse dans les douze coups mis en jeu
le réveil dans les 12 coups de midi et
c'est vrai quoi la j'adorais et wayan
plus miss la pétait un peu si les papas
tables étaient les gens les vrais gens
qu'on avait un cahier pas là c'était
calcutta
ils ont été imités hymne et apple sommes
comme ça merci d'être là et ya pascal
qu'on avait déjà reçu psychanalyse
psychothérapeute et c'est vrai que cette
histoire des jeux télé ça peut rendre
fou et toi cyril alors toi tu as gagné
plus de 300000 euros grâce au jeu ça a
complètement changé ta [ __ ] au
complètement tu faisais quoi vent avant
j'ai été j'étais journaliste d'accord
mais je travaillais comme journaliste
sportif un accord et puis est arrivée
cette histoire mais à trois mois tu
t'inscris comme on a eu l'idée
d'inscrire comme ça parce que j'ai
commencé à faire un jeu par hasard
j'avais accompagné un pote sur un
premier jeu ça avait bien fonctionné je
me suis dit tiens je suis à l'aise
devant les caméras pourquoi pas donc je
me suis fait aux 12 coups de midi
casting je suis arrivé il ya beaucoup de
monde au casting des 12 coups de midi
dans la forêt peut se distinguer et ses
escapades pour distinguer je suis parti
dans des imitations je me suis présenté
comme le plus mauvais imitateur de
france je suis parti dans des imitations
mais vraiment est requis de qui de tout
le monde c'est à dire mais on l'aurait
on les reconnaissait pas puisqu'en
l'occurrence
actuellement mauvais qu'on leur
connaissait pas ça les a fait marrer
sont dit tiens lui peut être rigolo bon
au niveau des connaissances ça se tenait
pas mal donc il s'en dit allez on va le
prendre et puis c'est comme si la
réglementation qui avait tu peux pas
nous en faire une fleur nicolas sarkozy
nicolas sarkozy
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
castaldi que cela dit
je dirige voulaient ils adorent ils
étaient excellents vraiment et
d'ailleurs il est toujours cette
victoire donc tu accueilles gagner en
2012 tu es devenu maître de midi tu as
gagné trois cent cinquante six mille
euros c'est énorme et grâce à ça va
complètement changer de vie qu'est ce
qui s'est passé là bas ce qui s'est
passé c'est que bon j'étais journaliste
donc j'avais des j'écrivais mais je
m'étais jamais vraiment voilà j'avais
j'avais un peu de complexes à de me dire
tiens est ce que tu as écrit à vraiment
et faire des romans et là effectivement
avec cette aisance financière noël me
suis dis bah écoute tu as de maintenant
de consacrer à ça et puis depuis je me
consacre à mes romans le quatrième sort
le 20 octobre prochain aux éditions du
masque et voilà maintenant je dois déjà
subi de ta passion voilà c'est ça alors
tu as gagné beaucoup d'argent d'un seul
coup
comment tu l'as gérer ça parce que c'est
compliqué maintenant à quand on reçoit
une telle somme comment ça se passe
d'ailleurs dans les jeux télé pour que
les gens comprennent moi je ne sais même
pas c'est à dire que là tu finis c'était
donc le sait plus quelle date c'était en
2012 tu finis le jeu et même maître de
midi parce que l'émission est
enregistrée donc il faut que ça passe
pour que tu prennes l'argent il faut
attacher un truc c'est qu'on télé il
faut que l'émission soit diffusée pour
que vous soyez payer mais
j'ai par exemple un exemple d'une
émission de m6 appelée mission à
millions oui vous avez eu un des jeux et
les jouets t est enregistrée et le jeu
avait démarré c'était à l'époque où il y
avait qui veut gagner des millions ouais
y'a même pas qu'ils ference mission
avignon plusieurs semaines plus tard il
ya une jeune femme moins jeunes hommes
qui gagnent énormément d'argent en
mission à minuit sauf que l'émission
n'est jamais passé le mec je crois
demande un million et quelques démission
n'est jamais passée n'a jamais été
pénible puisque le patron de m6 avait
décidé à l'époque petit parce qu'il me
fait pas du tout d'arrêter l'émission
donc vous rendez compte vous rentrez
chez vous et à d'autres femmes j'ai
gagné un million et là le lendemain
envoyé émission arrêtez vous dire c'est
dur mais c'est donc ça passe c'est dans
le pontiac parce que c'est comme contre
sedan le contrat alors vous cyrine vous
gagnez trois cent cinquante six mille
euros comment ça se passe on le reçoit
un chèque commence donc soit le chain
d'entrée pour un peu de temps après une
semaine ou deux semaines à la fin des
temps doit l'attendre tous les jours le
chèque ouais ouais moi confiance après
j'avais confiance je connais un petit
peu
sérieuses et très sérieuses très
carillon problème du bon l'instant quand
même le chèque à 56 millions le lait
qu'elle côtoie tu vas à la boîte aux
lettres tu as un prospectus de dominer
moment là le matin tu étais content
d'école factoring et quand il est arrivé
j'ai vu tchèque j'ai dit ça y est c'est
là ces bourses et le ton changement de
vie là bas mais oui megan en plus à
l'époque je me souviens sans rentrer
dans les détails je tiens un peu diable
par la queue sincèrement 5saint certains
tweaks angie messi qui vous libère total
sur chivu qui vous ouvre des
perspectives dans quai cantaranne rishek
de trois cent cinquante six mille euros
bon il me dit d'où vous venez d'avec ça
franchement ils m'ont dit et c'est si
vous que ça vient d'où parce que mon
banquier connais mes comptes
salaire dit ça vient d'où ce elle
manquait regardez pas les 12 coups de
midi c'est un moment donné j'étais
obligé de lui expliquer
le processus et a bien reçu
voilà monsieur legendre si vous voulez
bien où ça fait
le truc qu'on a envie de savoir c'est ce
que tes relations avec ton entourage ont
changé on va parler la même pression
aussi à bouilhou qui va avec ne sais pas
d'ailleurs s'il a déjà reçu les laisse
ou bono il va nous en parler il sera
avec nous dans un instant ses plus gros
gagnant de toute l'histoire des choses
est ce que la relation était proche a
changé alors avec mais très proche non
c'est à dire tes proches et est marié
moi je suis marié j'ai deux enfants
moment c'était juste pour thoiras ouais
mais mes enfants en plus c'était petit
donc ils sont venus sur le plateau
plusieurs fois mais comprenez pas
exactement quand il s'en vend une tétine
en or ils sont
arrivés là on est passé à autre chose a
effectivement mais les proches proche
non parce que franchement voilà c'était
c'est votre cocon voilà c'est les gens
sur qui on peut compter après il ya le
deuxième cercle et là c'est différent
d'ailleurs par les réseaux sociaux les
amis de fac qui m'ont repris contact
avec moi away est assez drôle et moi
comme je suis un peu naïf ouais moi
j'étais très heureux de les revoir et
donc les mecs me balance des photos nous
en vacances en espagne etc tu te
souviens c'était le bon temps dans votre
[ __ ] c'est vrai qu'on en a bien
profité c'était vraiment génial et puis
passent une semaine deux semaines on se
remémore les bons souvenirs super et la
troisième semaine il fait je t'ai pas
dit mais je suis un peu en galère de
fruits est ce que tu pourrais peut-être
je sais que c était patek de leur moto
[Rires]
et d'autre et le traitement des nausées
et maman des deux incroyables une
déception énorme parce que oui en plus
naïfs à
356 peut-être
mais je suis toujours le même mois
servait pas changé donc super naïf et
dans la famille et tout ya pas d un
genre maintenant à même avec les potes
c'est toi qui paye au resto tous à clé
hu a eu un petit peu ça au départ a
déconné mais il ya toujours des petites
blagues c'est maintenant et avec ça tu
ne payes le resto sur le ton de la
blague bien sûr mais moi je suis sympa
je lui dis évidemment c'est pour moi
après il ya eu une grosse notoriété mine
de rien parce que vrai ça fait combien
d'émissions moi j'ai fait 71 émission
mais c'est vrai qu'on se rend pas compte
de l'impact c'est à dire que regrets
voilà je crois que ces trois millions et
demi ou 4 millions tous les tous les
midis sur tf1 sur et moi pendant
l'émission une fois que j'avais
enregistré que j'avais terminé mon
j'étais encore en diffusion et j'avais
eu l'idée avec mes enfants et ma femme
pareille d'aller au zoo impose au zoo de
beauval de façon très décontractée
tranquille et la mamie animaux tu
reconnaîtras
gentil la légèreté ma famille elle me
dit toi tu es de la famille et dont
hélas hélas hélas on voit l'impact des
choses ça c'est incroyable parce que là
c'était pas un pas sans dire est en plus
j'avais mon petit surnom de l'époque que
j'ai toujours gardé que je te confie et
gens du ce coup sacré en plus une
propriété subir fr voilà je trouve fives
lâche confie une proximité mais par
contre toujours toujours bienveillant
bien sûr et super alors très surprenant
mais éminemment sympathique alors moi
toi tu t'en es bien sorti c'est
réglementé heureux voilà tu as su tu as
hâte a permis de changer de vie mais
c'est vrai que on va recevoir bruno je
pense que pour lui aussi c'est à très
bien se passer mais lui c'est une somme
incroyable un bruno c'est le plus grand
gagnant de toute l'histoire de la
télévision en plus il
il est très sympathique et c est ce qu
il ya des gens qui peuvent mal de vivre
et bien évidemment et encore 300 mille
euros c'est pas grand chose en amont par
les as d'aller gagner 800 milles aux
états unis on gagne des millions
auxquels les bus ça va mais ce qui est
très intéressant mais l'autre camp mais
que ça vaille avec son clip l'azergues
il faut revenir dans la réalité parce
que quoi qu'il en soit il ya un star
system le schtroumpf chi c'est quand
même assez intéressant et fêtons vous
balancez cela mais vous êtes à m'en
donnez vous donnez le chouchou également
de ces émissions parce que quoi qu'il en
soit vous êtes une sorte de vainqueur de
héros il ya toute une sémantique
également psychologique par rapport à
ces gagnants ses vainqueurs alors c'est
quasiment mais comme les jeux du cirque
on mais sauf que ces intellectuels ou
pas c'est les star system également par
affaire et a pris 3,6 alors tu me tues
vos amis ne rate rarement
[Rires]
déjà perdu
discuter de tout cela c'est dire sur
quelles valeurs a effectivement on va
juger un euro sur une personne sur sa
tête